parce que c'est vrai qu'à un moment on a
dit qu'on travaillait pas on a tous
beaucoup travaillé cette année et
j'aurais pu mettre illimité parce que vu
le nombre de sms qu'on a reçu cette
année je pense qu'ils ont un forfait
c'est mérité car ils pas tous les wc
bien ils font leur boulot mais met donc
on est passé par toutes les émotions et
voilà c'est très très riche cette année
car on aura l'interro surprise pas grave
puisque on l'interrogé remise de tout ce
qui s'est passé dans l'année mais juste
avant j'ai fait une petite caméra cachée
voilà j'ai voulu laisser certains
chroniqueurs laurent bureau comme à
chaque fois que je voulais leur parler à
des gens des plages et quelques-uns
regard d'ange été annulé coup de bol
[Musique]
financièrement parlant chez vous un
bonus enfants
parler d'un magnifique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les données la famille royale et tu
deviens ce que tu vois avec le patronat
je fais des soins c'est quoi ces romans
ou à la journée
[Applaudissements]
parfois
je pouvais pas leur garde son mot pour
résumer l'année c'est vrai qu'il y
chambly
je vous ai oublié mais beaucoup parler
c'est à mon sens oui non maman moss et
rigolade voilà maintenant bas on m'a dit
c'était déjà free a donc j'allais
chercher un synonyme voilà donc j'ai dit
rigolade web de septembre à juin je
pense que j'aime autant rigoler dans ma
vie je crois que j'ai eu un fou rire par
jour et pour moi c'est exceptionnel
[Musique]